neutral why is the relations with the
twani are traditionally filled with
suspicious scandinavia has no real
interest in poland and we are separated
from the southern europe ID checks the
slowest the Hungarians and the awesomes
all of whom jaunt three consider
reviving the cooperation in the legacy
of the Vienna Budapest tradition Poland
found a special bomb in a close alliance
with America it being an ally of a great
power is not an easy task waking up as a
vassal state one day may come as an
unpleasant surprise the only neighboring
country that in a long perspective might
share our views and have convergent
interest is Ukraine the finding and calm
clamp for action is yet not easy first
of all as i already said according to
brussels ukraine is not in europe for
the n is nearly independent states and
that includes ukraine do you venture out
with an initiative of wider europe
neighborhood it does not provide a
perspective of membership second of all
ukraine is the easternmost fragment of
the central european wide claims only
recently sounded celebrated the 350th
anniversary of the Paris of agreement
back then the UK in White Plains also
had a chance to gain sovereignity but as
we know too well it failed and with time
muscle to get all took us all by sheer
miracle the end of the 20th century
offers yet another chance a prospect of
creating and establishing and Ukrainian
state entity with the capital and here
and an economy that would allow for
independent development for Poland as we
often point out it is a winning ticket
on the lottery
history I have to admit that back in
1991 I had little confidence in the
success of this plan Moscow will not
allow I reasoned yet over ten years have
passed and the Ukrainian state does not
only exist but it's recently managed to
sign border agreement with Russia it is
a great success one well worth
sacrificing the sea of Azoff and some
prestige the facts are what counts
although the Ambassador governor resides
in here although the Ukrainian oligarchs
are only younger brothers to the Russian
ones although the moscow-based KGB and
its successors do is it a peace in
Ukraine although jaani dushman sugar is
not a democrat or even a mildly in line
that subscribe and the Ukrainian
political party brings to mind up it
shows still the state exists and that's
what is the most important finding a
solution to the problem is only a matter
of time we all have to fight them living
in this region the differences lie only
in the intensity of negative symptoms
the further east the higher the demand
of normality the production prerequisite
to the success of Ukraine is primarily
the constant wheel of this of a
significant majority of citizens to
build a separate state one independent
of feminine and the fathering of an
opportunity to anchor the kiev-based
stake in the western city silly
stabilization of tradition this is an
undertaking to which the west and the
dust Poland must commit itself it
becomes clear that the United Europe is
too contented and took fearful to take
up grounds of dispute with Moscow
Brussels will not compete with the
Russians over the influence on Kia the
only power of trade are the Americans
convincing washing
than to assume and come a consistent
active policy in this region is
difficult yet I believe not impossible
polish policy towards Kiev is not very
tolerant divided declarative support for
Ukraine often did not result in any
practical activity and at times it was
considered that the toys diplomacy in
the East should primarily address both
the strategy of Polish policy towards
Ukraine must be grounded on the premise
that anything that might help further
confirm it statehood support Ukrainian
authorities